I grew up to study the brain because I
have a brother who has been diagnosed
with a brain disorder schizophrenia and
as a sister and later as a scientist I
wanted to understand why is it that I
can take my dreams I can connect them to
my reality and I can make my dreams come
true what is it about my brother's brain
and his schizophrenia that he cannot
connect his dreams to a common and
shared reality so they instead become
delusion so I dedicated my career to
research into the severe mental
illnesses and I moved from my home state
of Indiana to Boston where I was working
in the lab of dr. Francine Venice in the
Harvard Department of Psychiatry and in
the lab we were asking the question what
are the biological differences between
the brains of individuals who would be
diagnosed as normal control as compared
with the brains of individuals diagnosed
with schizophrenia schizoaffective or
bipolar disorder so we were essentially
mapping the micro circuitry of the brain
which cells are communicating with which
cells with which chemicals and then in
what quantities of those chemicals so
there was a lot of meaning in my life
because I was performing this type of
research during the day but then in the
evenings and and on the weekends I
traveled as an advocate for Nami the
National Alliance on Mental Illness but
on the morning of December 10 1996 I
woke up to discover that I had a brain
disorder of my own a blood vessel
exploded in the left half of my brain
and in the course of four hours I
watched my brain completely deteriorate
in its ability to process all
information on the morning of the
hemorrhage I could not walk talk read
write or recall any of my life I
essentially became an infant
in a woman's body if you've ever seen a
human brain it's obvious that the two
hemispheres are completely separate from
one another and I have brought for you a
real human brain
thank you sir so this is a real human
brain this is the front of the brain the
back of the brain with a spinal cord
hanging down and this is how it would be
positioned inside of my head and when
you look at the brain it's obvious that
the two cerebral cortices are completely
separate from one another for those of
you who understand computers our right
hemisphere functions like a parallel
processor while our left hemisphere
functions like a serial processor the
two hemispheres do communicate with one
another through the corpus callosum
which is made up of some 300 million
axonal fibers but other than that the
two hemispheres are completely separate
because they process information
differently each of our hemisphere think
about different things they care about
different things and dare I say they
have very different personalities excuse
me
thank you it's been a joy hour right
human hemisphere is all about this
present moment it's all about right here
right now our right hemisphere it thinks
in pictures and it learns
kinesthetically through the movement of
our bodies information in the form of
energy streams in simultaneously through
all of our sensory systems and then it
explodes into this enormous collage of
what this present moment looks like what
this present moment smells like and
tastes like what it feels like and what
it sounds like I am an energy being
connected to the energy all around me
through the consciousness of my right
hemisphere we are energy beings
connected to one another through the
consciousness of our right hemispheres
as one human family and right here right
now
we are brothers and sisters on this
planet here to make the world a better
place and in this moment we are perfect
we are whole and we are beautiful my
left hemisphere our left hemisphere is a
very different place our left hemisphere
thinks linearly and methodically our
left hemisphere is all about the past
and it's all about the future our left
hemisphere is designed to take that
enormous collage of the present moment
and start picking out details details
and more details about those details it
then categorizes and organizes all that
information associates it with
everything in the past we've ever
learned and projects into the future all
of our possibilities and our left
hemisphere thinks in language it's that
ongoing brain chatter that connects me
and my internal world to my external
world it's that little voice that says
to me hey you got to remember to pick up
an analyst on your way home I need them
in the morning
it's that calculating intelligence that
knows that reminds me when I have to do
my laundry but perhaps most important
it's that little voice that says to me I
am I am and as soon as my left
hemisphere says to me I am I become
separate I become a single solid
individual separate from the energy flow
around me and separate from you and this
is the portion of my brain that I lost
on the morning of my stroke on the
morning of a stroke I woke up to a
pounding pain behind my left eye and it
was the kind of pain caustic pain that
you get when you bite into ice cream and
it just gripped me and then it released
me and then it just gripped me and then
it released me and it was very unusual
for me to ever experience any kind of
pain so I thought okay I'll just start
my normal routine so I got up and I
jumped onto my cardio glider which is a
full body full exercise machine
and I'm jamming away on this thing and
I'm realizing that my hands look like
primitive claws grasping onto the bar
and I thought that's very peculiar and I
looked down at my body and I thought
whoa I'm a weird-looking thing and it
was as though my consciousness had
shifted away from my normal perception
of reality where I'm the person on the
machine having the experience to some
esoteric space where I'm witnessing
myself having this experience there was
all very peculiar and my headache was
just getting worse so I get off the
machine and I'm walking across my living
room floor and I realized that
everything inside of my body has slowed
way down and every step is very rigid
and very deliberate there's no fluidity
to my pace and there's this constriction
in my area of perception so I'm just
focused on internal systems and I'm
standing in my bathroom getting ready to
step into the shower and I could
actually hear the dialogue inside of my
body I heard a little voice saying okay
you muscles you got a contract and you
muscles you relaxed and now I lost my
balance and I'm propped up against the
the wall and I looked down at my arm and
I realized that I can no longer define
the boundaries of my body I can't define
where I begin and where I end because
the atoms and the molecules of my arm
blended with the atoms and molecules of
the wall and only could detect was this
energy energy and I'm asking myself what
is wrong with me what is going on and in
that moment my brain chatter my left
hemisphere brain chatter went totally
silent just like someone took a remote
control and pushed the mute button total
silence and at first I was shocked to
find myself inside of a silent mind but
then I was immediately captivated by the
magnificence of the energy around me and
because I could no longer identify the
boundaries of my body I felt enormous
and expansive I felt at one with all the
energy that was and it was
beautiful there then all of a sudden my
left hemisphere comes back online and it
says to me hey we had a problem we got a
problem we gotta get some help but I'm
going oh I got a problem I got a problem
so it's like okay okay I got a problem
but then I immediately drifted right
back out into the consciousness and I
fictionally refer to this space as lala
land but it was beautiful there imagine
what it would be like to be totally
disconnected from your brain chatter
that connects you to the external world
so here I am in this space and my job
and any stress related to mice my job it
was gone and I felt lighter in my body
and imagine all of the relationships in
the external world and any stressors
related to any of those they were gone
and I felt this sense of peacefulness
and imagine what it would feel like to
lose 37 years of emotional baggage oh I
felt euphoria euphoria it was beautiful
there and then again my left hemisphere
comes online and it says hey you've got
to pay attention we've got to get help
and I'm thinking I've got to get help I
got to focus so I get out of the shower
and I'm mechanically dressed and I'm
walking around my apartment and I'm
thinking I got to get to work I got to
get to work can I Drive
can I Drive and in that moment my right
arm went totally paralyzed by my side
did I realize oh my gosh am I having a
stroke I'm having a stroke and then the
next thing my brain says to me is wow
this is so cool this is so cool how many
brain scientists have the opportunity to
study their own brain from the inside
out
and then it crosses my mind but I'm a
very busy woman time for a strong it's
like okay I can't stop this drunk from
happening so I'll do this for a week or
two and then I'll get back to my routine
okay so I got a call help I got a call
work I couldn't remember the number at
work so I remembered in my office I had
a business card with my number on him so
I go into my business room I pull out a
three inch stack of business cards and
I'm looking at the card on top and even
though I could see clearly in my mind's
eye what my business card looked like I
couldn't tell if this was my card or not
cuz all I could see were pixels and the
pixels of the words blended with the
pixels of the background and the pixels
of the symbols and I just couldn't tell
and then I would wait for what I call a
wave of clarity and in that moment I
would be able to reattach to normal
reality and I could tell that's not the
card that's not the card that's not the
card it took me 45 minutes to get one
inch down inside of that stack of cards
in the mean time for 45 minutes the
hemorrhage is getting bigger in my left
hemisphere I do not understand numbers I
do not understand the telephone but it's
the only plan I have so I take the foam
pad and I put it right here I take the
business card I put it right here and
I'm matching the shape of the squiggles
on the card to the shape of the
squiggles on the foam pad but then I
would drift back out into lala land and
not remember if when I come back if I'd
already dialed those numbers so I had to
wield my paralyzed alarm like a stomp
and cover the numbers as I went along
and pushed them so that as I would come
back to normal reality I'd be able to
tell yes I've already dialed that number
eventually the whole number gets dialed
and I'm listening to the phone and my
colleague picks up the phone and he says
to me whoa
and I think that myself oh my gosh he
sounds like a golden retriever and so I
say to him clear in my mind I say to him
this is Jill I need help and what comes
out of my voice is whoa I think oh my
gosh I sound like a golden retriever
so I couldn't know I didn't know that I
couldn't speak or understand language
until I tried so he recognizes that I
need help and he and he gets me help and
a little while later I'm I'm riding in
an ambulance from one hospital across
Boston to Mass General Hospital and I
curl up into a little fetal ball and
just like a balloon with the last last
bit of air of just just right out of the
balloon I just felt my energy lift and
just I felt my spirit surrender and in
that moment I knew that I was no longer
the choreographer of my life and either
the doctors rescue my body and give me a
second chance at life or this was
perhaps my moment of transition when I
woke later that afternoon I was shocked
to discover that I was still alive when
I felt my spirit surrender I said
goodbye to my life and my mind was now
suspended between two very opposite
planes of reality stimulation coming in
through my sensory systems felt like
pure pain light burned my brain like
wildfire and sounds were so loud and
chaotic that I could not pick a voice
out from the background noise and I just
wanted to escape because I could not
identify the position of my body in
space I felt enormous and expansive like
a genie just liberated from her bottle
and my spirit soared free like a great
whale Glide
through a sea of silent euphoria nirvana
I found nirvana I remember thinking
there's no way I would ever be able to
squeeze the enormousness of myself back
inside this tiny little body but then I
realized but I'm still alive I'm still
alive and I have found nirvana and and
if I have found Nirvana and I'm still
alive then everyone who is alive can
find nirvana and I pictured a world
filled with beautiful peaceful
compassionate loving people who knew
that they could come to this space at
any time and that they could purposely
choose to step to the right of their
left hemispheres and find this peace and
then I realized what a tremendous gift
this experience could be what what a
stroke of insight this could be to how
we live our lives and it motivated me to
recover two-and-a-half weeks after the
hemorrhage
the surgeons went in and they removed
the blood clot the size of a golf ball
that was pushing on my language centers
Here I am with my momma who's a true
angel in my life it took me eight years
to completely recover so who are we we
are the life force power of the universe
with manual dexterity and two cognitive
minds and we have the power to choose
moment by moment who and how we want to
be in the world right here right now I
can step into the consciousness of my
right hemisphere where we are I am the
life-force power of the universe I am
the life-force power the 50 trillion
beautiful molecular geniuses the makeup
my
form at one with all that is or I can
choose to step into the consciousness of
my left hemisphere where I become a
single individual a solid separate from
the flow separate from you
I am dr. Jill Bolte Taylor intellectual
neuroanatomist these are the we inside
of me which would you choose which do
you choose
and win I believe that the more time we
spend choosing to run the deep inner
peace circuitry of our right hemispheres
the more peace we will project into the
world and the more peaceful our planet
will be and I thought that was an idea
worth spreading
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you